peu brillant merci héros c'est la parole
est à madame stéphanie pernaut beau donc
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre nous sommes
à six mois de l'élection présidentielle
et il est temps aujourd'hui de faire
votre bilan pas le nôtre que vous nous
asséner à longueur de questions
d'actualité sur un mandat qui s'est
terminée il ya quatre ans le vôtre et
notamment en matière d'emploi la
croissance aujourd'hui en france est
très faible la plupart de nos collègues
européens ont un taux de croissance plus
important que le nôtre parce qu'ils ont
eu le courage de mener des réformes
structurelles dans leur pays des
réformes difficiles mais qui ont permis
de tenir notamment en italie et en
allemagne qu'avons nous fait nous
aujourd'hui vous avez ouvert les vannes
des dépenses publiques et vous avez fait
en sorte de servir toutes les personnes
qui étaient censés voter pour vous vous
avez fait peser sur les ménages un choc
fiscal insoutenable notamment dans les
classes moyennes vous avez mis en place
une complexité des procédures qui rend
l'économie difficile à mettre en oeuvre
et vous avez tué l'entrepreneuriat la
dette publique se sont aussi à six mois
de l'élection présidentielle l'ensemble
des cadeaux que le président de la
république offre en se levant le matin à
des catégories qui demain pourraient
voter pour lui parce qu'il est en train
de se noyer au bord de la noyade le
problème aussi que vous avez mis c'est
la formation vous avez mis en place le
plan emploi formation vous avez demandé
sur la dette financée à un milliard
trois sur la dette à pôle emploi de
maître dans les régions en place des
formations professionnelles votre
objectif c'est l inversion de la courbe
du chômage vous n'y êtes même pas arrivé
qu'en est il de ce plan formation emploi
où en sommes nous de ce plan formation
emploi des personnes ont cru aller dans
des formations et en définitive ne
trouveront pas d'emploi ensuite c'était
une imposture alors monsieur le premier
ministre quand vous êtes capable de
dépenser un milliard trois sur la dette
pour inverser une courbe du chômage qui
ne s'inverse pas parce que vous êtes
inactif de quoi allez vous être capable
de nous dire dans le cadre de votre
bilan on aimerait connaître votre milan
ben en matière d'emploi et savoir
comment vous allez faire pour justifier
quatre ans aujourd'hui d'inaction en
matière d'emploi
merci
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls
madame la députée vous avez vous avez
raison le temps
le temps attendait la suite le temps du
merci monsieur le président le temps du
bilan le temps des propositions
le temps du projet vient et d'ailleurs
et c'est plutôt une belle chose pour la
démocratie votre formation il participe
grâce à la primaire comme nous avions
une ou même l'occasion de le faire il y
a cinq ans et c'est important
c'est important qu'il y ait ce débat
démocratique oui bien sûr il ya un
problème de croissance il ya un problème
de croissance dans notre économie en
europe d'une manière générale poignet
l'exemple de l'italie et même de
l'allemagne aujourd'hui vous voyez bien
que le niveau de croissance au niveau de
la zone euro reste faible mais on peut
se poser y compris une autre question
est ce que nous connaîtrons dans les
années qui viennent dans le monde tel
qu'il est avec son développement
économique des niveaux de croissance
très importante non dont je crois qu'il
faut investir massivement investir
massivement dans l'éducation je me suis
exprimé ce matin investir massivement
dans l'industrie parce que vous auriez
pu commencer par là et je vous lis très
honnêtement madame la députée c'est pas
pour envoyer un bilan mais ce qu'il faut
reconnaître c'est que dans les années
2000 alors que l'allemagne faisait un
certain nombre de réformes coûteuses
mais utile nous perdions notre économie
et notre industrie en compétitivité est
ce que je remarque christophe sirugue
aurait pu le remarquer marty c'est que
le niveau aujourd'hui
industriels 7 ce déclin cette baisse de
notre industrie s'est stoppée et que
nous reprenons parce qu'il ya le pays a
parce qu'il ya l'industrie du futur
parce que nous investissons aussi dans
les énergies renouvelables dans la
transition écologique donc cessons d
sujet suffisamment important enfin
madame la députée on aura l'occasion
évidemment d'avoir ce débat il ya
quelque chose que je que je récuse et
que par ailleurs je trouve que dans le
débat public n'apporte pas grand chose
c'est l'histoire d des cadeaux mais mais
de quoi voulez-vous parler voulais
parler des moyens que nous avons donnés
à la police des moyens que nous avons
donné aux aux enseignants des moyens que
nous avons donné aux fonctionnaires
d'une manière générale qui font la
fierté de notre pays voulait parler des
moyens et des aides que nous avons porté
aux agriculteurs mais découpés la france
ainsi en catégorie en cadeaux entre ce
qui serait privilégiée par la majorité
entre ce qui serait assisté c'est
exactement ce qu'il ne faut pas faire
moi je pense qu'une politique qui se
défend c'est celle qui s'adresse à tous
les français qui permet la cohésion qui
permet au moment où la société française
évidemment tarauder pâle populisme avec
ses factures et ses divisions au
contraire d'unir alors madame la députée
et posé une question sérieuse lourd de
sens alors oui bilan contre bilan
proposition contre-proposition défend le
modèle républicain le modèle social
alors que d'autres veulent le mettre en
cause moi je suis prêt je serai fier non
seulement de défendre un bilan mais
surtout de proposer parce que nous avons
besoin donner du sens donné un projet au
pays de redonner confiance et la fierté
aux français - madame la député j si
près